the o2
oh seeger with another bullet handle it
got it all away don't worry about it one
out
well he's seen some bullets mike those
reactions
are still great made a play to his left
in the first game and this right here
a hanging breaking ball it's a mistake
and kyle reaction
it's a nice hop over there no rushing to
throw at all just lob it across the
infield
first pitch to dylan moore on the way
home he swings and socks this out to
left field
out of the warning track back by the
wall and gone
how about this from dylan moore to start
the top of the third
mariners bp at camden yards continues
dillon going deep and it's one nothing
mariners in the third inning
first home run of the season for dylan
moore he didn't waste any time jumping
on this first pitch from zimmerman
middle in a little bit down and he got
hold of it and got it out to left field
nice swing by dylan
this is his thought major league
baseball's had before like
here's a ground ball to third from
hanager five
four and three double play
[Applause]
go back to that first inning of game one
where the orioles had the home run from
mancini two more hits they only have
one hit since then in eight innings
galbas slugs one in the right hanger at
the wall
it is gone
ask and you shall receive
a flag court shot for freddie galvez
his first home run is in oriole freddie
galvez chokes up on the bat just a
little bit he goes upstairs and gets on
top of this ball
take a look at it coming right at you
just a fastball elevated it's jersey
high it's letter high
a good move to the baseball some really
quick hands to get on top of an elevated
fastball
and tie this game up now one to one here
at the bottom of the third
two outs here's mitch there's mitch
riding one deep
just looking up he's putting the bullpen
again
it's 2-1 seattle mitch hadiger
two homer day and america's have the
lead
110 on the exit v low change up 84 miles
an hour
over 400 feet to get it out to that
bullpen is that loud enough
i think so
2-2 pitch oh he got him
just done sparkling performance six
strikeouts in his five innings of work
and he is look
fantastic justin dunn one of the better
performances we've seen him turn in mike
and didn't get much help from the umpire
but he was in the strike zone
working ahead a lot of first pitch
strikes for him today then expanding the
zone
pretty good breaking ball today you can
see you're going to chase the breaking
ball out of the zone
it's good stuff all the way around and
he didn't seem to get frustrated
by some of the calls he wasn't getting
from the umpire about that 95 at the
bottom of the zone
struck out the side and a fourth
a boatload of new concepts just new
terminology sometimes and ways to
measure
there's just data now right i mean you
know
good pick at third by franco nice
defensive hitting this is turning out to
be for michael franco
and talk about something good a little
good backhand pick by franco strong
throw across the diamond to mancini
and tramell is going to go for second
cisco's throw the tag
he's out
we'll pick you up trey will pick up your
glove more specifically
tag by ruiz and the inning comes to an
end if the orioles
flash some leather
[Music]
double play always one time how big was
that
oh my god that's the infielder in him
that bill is just talking about
oh get rid of it quickly i'll tell you
what that's pretty good play bill
a little half swing here back to the
mound wide throw but trey kept his foot
on the back
you know salsa's got that good fastball
little cutter
split as well backhand side and there's
the throw
and he's got his foot on there
follow two strikes freddie galvez
middleton deals
bouncing ball middleton scoop underhand
ball game
murders sweep the doubleheader take
three out of four
now four and one in one run games a 2-1
final of beauty excellent pitching for
the mariners just enough
offense the bullpen outstanding